we have to help Charles he's devastated
I hate seeing him like this breakups are
cartoony thumbs down they make people
feel faced with x's for the eyes
what does that even mean the English
language cannot fully capture the depth
and complexity of my thoughts so I'm
incorporating Emoji into my speech to
better express myself Blinky face oh
Lord Gina made me call people and tell
them she was dead to see how they'd
react
crying a little
you should be
Now call my other Grandma I can't
imagine the 99 without you don't worry I
have a parting gift for all of you I
printed time for Gina's opinion hoodies
for you with your names on them yep
there you go oh that's fun so like time
for Jake's opinion what are you insane
no it says time for Gina's opinion and
large text on the back and then your
names are stitched really tiny on the
front I had to guess at some of the
spellings Arnie you should make me your
campaign manager I was born for politics
I have great hair and I love lying
Gina's authentic stolen police badges
how can I help hey it's Peralta Oh Hey
Jake hey do you carry a hair dryer in
your purse of course I'm not an animal
Gina was right about the campaign sir
I'm surprised he hasn't marched in here
to say I told you so she wouldn't do
that you're right Amy
for life you're 100
I would never say that
did you have enough time to read at all
yes okay good Gino what are you thinking
about right now
I was thinking how I would make the
perfect American president based upon my
skill set dance ability and bloodlust
his
Ashanti
hey Charles you're pretty excited about
Jake being back yeah it's like when I
was a kid and my grandma came home from
the hospital only better because Jake's
not unresponsive every time you talk I
hear that sound that plays when Pac-Man
dies
Trent Bryce where are we with the name
we've narrowed it down to two choices PD
or Paulie with all due respect that
pigeon is clearly a Ray J
hi Gina linetti the human form of the
100 emoji Gina I was outside on business
and I purchased a box of assorted tweet
treats I give you the first pick do you
mind if I did
curious
your favorite shape was a square and yet
now when you're given a choice between
round cookies and square blondies you
opt for the cookie you opt for the
circle yes but it's not about shapes I'm
choosing a cookie over a blondie I'm
Whimsical but I'm not a lunatic but
butter eggs flour sugar baking soda
chocolate Salt vanilla the basic
building blocks are identical the only
Salient difference
their shape
you're trying to get me bumped out of
i-9c 3g6
you don't like that the test put us in
the same category that is so rude do you
know how many basic [ __ ] would kill
to have the same personality as me
beardo
it's time for you to get out of
Charles's house today hang on
you don't tell me what to do uh that's
where you're wrong baby girl I run this
Precinct watch this Scully go to sleep
okay
you think you can intimidate me yeah
when I was undercover Jimmy the butcher
cut off my little toe with Garden shoes
and made me eat it as a loyalty test
I've been through hell big deal I worked
at a sunglass kiosk at the mall for four
years so not only have I been through
hell I was assistant manager there
you're gonna get out of Chucky's house
and what's more you're gonna pay them
rent for the night you spent there
fine one more thing babe you're gonna
thank us both right now
thank you you're welcome
thank you you're welcome
Belgium you just needed to be out
entry at the door but the window was
Jimmy you don't have locks on your
windows way to blame the victim sorry
I'm not rich like you missed one percent
it costs eight dollars you have a fur
bedspread why do you have so many Lycra
body suits and why do you need eight
full drawers of underwear because I'm
civilized let's talk iTalk more salty
salt we need an itemized list of
everything that was stolen I already
gave it to Captain Holt 160 dollars in
cash one TV one large painting of a
naked lady on a lion one set of Joseph
Gordon-Levitt nesting dolls wow wow I
made an Irreplaceable one music box that
plays she works hard for the money when
opened one knockoff designer clutch can
you just buy another knockoff no I can't
silly Sue because the label no longer
makes the original so the Sweatshop no
longer makes the knockoff
Can you estimate the value of everything
that was taken emotionally 700 million
dollars your problem is not that you're
troubled or at risk or bad dressers is
that trucker hat still come on
your problem is that you don't have
passion for anything my life turned
around when I found my passion
and today well I help to inspire you
with it
[Music]
you are beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in every single way
what are we thinking yes in the denim I
think I speak for everyone when I say
you're weird dancing was just weird fine
cops make 52 000 a year you never have
to stop at a red light and you get to
carry a gun who wants in
boom boom boom boom yes
Captain the kids want to know where a
Polly the pigeon is I told him he got
sucked up into an airplane engine is
that all right I can't put that
pigeonette on Gina lunch has defeated me
this is how it ends with me standing on
the urine soaked floor of an elementary
school bathroom and a third rate bird
costume
I quit no I did not follow you to PR to
watch you quit I followed you because
you're great and because you make
Everything You Touch better
and I figured PR would be the easiest
path to launching my reality show
lynetti set go I thought your reliving
show was to be called Gina in a bottle
no that was my fragrance line keep up
why so excited did you make the cover of
hair pulled back magazine the captain is
coming to my party I'm gonna give a
toast tell him how thankful I am to have
him in the precinct and officially ask
him to be my mentor wait are you only
hosting dinner because you want to suck
up to Halt not cool this was supposed to
be about friendship you said you were
only coming to see if my apartment was
the reason I was single or if it was my
personality like you suspected yeah but
that was before I knew I could get up on
this high horse love the view up here
click clap clip clap clip clap we're
sorry we doubted you sir we really saved
our bus I can't take credit for that
Gina linetti is the real hero here visit
Gina linetti more of a state of mind
like in a way